my good buddy and my friend from NFL
gameday morning Dallas Cowboys great let
me go bleach right hold on a minute
Michael Irvin in a home you've been in
the Hall of Fame 11 years in that crazy
I've never missed a trip here either 11
years ago was that yep stand up it's
amazing it is amazing when you think
about how time flies out I was joking
with Urlacher in there today you know
got every lacquer Randy I remember
calling Randy as a rookie I remember
playing Urlacher and basketball as
rookie was dunking from the free-throw
line up like oh my god it's a linebacker
looking for the free throw hot it is
definitely time to get out of this NFL
game well you saw that kind of stuff man
and even guys like Ray Lewis and b-dawg
you know I Ray Lewis I remember him
coming in the University of Miami that's
right you do University of Miami and
we're now we're talking about we're in
the Hall of Fame did you gather did you
in SAP him break a picture together
oh no we're taught that we should have
grabbed all of my god Kelly had
Hendrix's hear you say it we should have
Jim spoke great Jim close the meeting
today speaking and did a beautiful job
and just can you I know you know what
yeah I'll give you a conference of what
he was cheering and everything he was
talking about just what it means to him
and any and he shared with us and over
let's begin out of term that turn here
he has another surgery coming up you
know and and you can feel the room the
wait in the room fall because he's like
you're looking at him and he talked I
mean he has another surgery coming up
and he said he said these things he said
you know whatever happens in that
surgery and whatever happens I want you
to know that being in this room it's
been some of the greatest times in my
life you know and if God see fit to take
me anytime soon I wanted all of you guys
to know that what you all meant to me
and it's just you know it was it was it
was pretty touching the him talk it was
pretty touching to him talking it that
way it was off it's always said that the
luncheon is always an
one moment and certainly that was we had
just talked about the guys that we've
lost this year and and then he stood up
and started talking in it was just
touching and he wrapped it up huh he
wrapped it up with that could speak
after that Wow Irv I mean that's what
that's what it's all about it's a
brotherhood of men making this sport you
know what it is and in how its and
remembered and that's what I love about
this weekend it also starts a whole new
season you know remember the past as the
present in the future gets discussed who
runs it in there though well well
because I know deacons right past a few
years yeah Willy Lanier runs it right
now and then he's been the moderating
moderating it for the last few years and
everything so you know and and he he'll
pick a person to kind of pass the mic
around and you have to stand up give
your name in your class and we all take
turns welcoming in the new class and
sharing personal stories about whatever
we know about the new class you know
Chris Carter spoke about random miles
coming in to Minnesota and it was a
touching it was very touching he said
man how I ran he just made him better he
said was the first time he stepped on
the field and looked at a football
player and thought this dude is better
than me he said you know it was late in
his career but but Randy gave him a lot
of energy it was just an incredible
incredible moment rich and I'm going to
say this you know cuz cuz as I spoke in
that room and a few people spoke on it
that's what I was talking about you know
I know you can say what you will there's
no way to get this in Tennessee
Chattanooga it's impossible it's
impossible to get this in Tennessee
Chattanooga it's impossible for tío to
feel what that feels like
like what do we will feel tonight when
these guys are walking through a gut lit
of all the guys that you've had mired
all of your life and looked at all of
your life and wanted to mimic all of
your life you're walking through a gun
of all of those guys as they welcome you
in to this this unique fraternity and
family you can't get this in Tennessee
chatter you can't not get it um we spoke
about him in the room you did yes we
spoke about him I I spoke about him and
I said you know guy there were some
mixed emotions in the room because guys
are worried about this becoming or
someone this I'm setting a precedent for
people and now all of a sudden desire
I'm gonna celebrate it over here and I'm
going to celebrate it over and I want to
celebrate my induction over there and we
had some mixed feelings about it in the
room people spoke pretty strongly
because they felt that this was a not
towards them not showing up not being
here in district turning all of Famers
taking it personally the tio is not they
take the I take it personally yeah yes
and and and and and and I understand
that I understand that cuz I made a
commitment to all of those guys in that
room and a lot of us do every time we
step up that we will be here every year
that God gives us good health to show up
here cuz that's what we owe these guys
you know I and going back and forth with
this tio thing here the last few weeks
you know I get a lot of people on my on
my social media and and I'm including
Terrell Owens obscenity oh and I'm going
to be honest here you know and and and I
get a lot of my people rich African
America saying well tio would I know
anybody anything and all it is we can do
this I stopped saying that that's not
true you do all people stuff at you you
Oh your parents I'm your mother
something she bought you for nine months
you old herself the old or something as
an african-american we all Martin Luther
King something we all have something for
it for the sacrifices they are made we
all have something as a football player
I'm fit the fifteenth of 17 kids the
fifteenth of seventeen kids growing up
in our damn ghetto in Fort Lauderdale
I all the guys that came before me I owe
them something because they gave me an
opportunity to play a game and make a
living and pull my family bottom a
hellhole I owe them something I can't
even just they're just wrong
makes me raw to hear my people say that
we don't owe anybody anything yes the
hell we do
and yes the hell he do and I wish he was
here to get what he has earned in that
room and and and and I heard for that
he's not here to get well he has earned
in that room but we said this and I
spoke this I said I don't care what it
is whenever he does walk in this room
he's family
and it's the thing that separates teams
and organizations from family is if
you're on a team or an organization when
things go bad people start pointing
fingers but when things aren't right in
family everybody comes together and
whenever he walks in that room we were
hugger
and we will be together and be complete
well I mean it takes two to make a hug
you know and I yeah and I think he wants
to be in that room though I think he
really does yeah and he wants to feel
that love from all of these people I
just think he could not be brought to
look at some of the people in the room
that he thought he should have been in
before
including maybe even or we you know or
sooner but that's why you know including
some in the class but that's one of the
things we talked about it who had a
funny moment in there because you know
we all talk about this team is forever
and and we don't we don't measure in
this room well whose greater than who's
this who's that who's the greatest and
all of these things and we all are we're
all on equal terms are on equal ground
in this room because we all have a gold
jacket and nobody I'd never ever I swear
to you on my mother and father's grave
and all alike I've never ever heard one
Hall of Famer - heard others say well I
was a first-ballot you worked you were
not now that we never had in my 11 years
in that room I've never heard it because
once you ain't you're in nobody talks
about all of those things
and and I when I spoke I said my my
thing that that I hate most for teal is
he's allowed a temporary pain a
temporary pain to overshadow this
permanent thing because this is
permanent
Oh a mom is permanent if he gives a
speech at Tennessee chatter no but you
would you go it may live today it may
never year but it won't live forever
it won't live forever when you give a
speech here it will live forever and
it's important to live forever because
when he's dead and gone his great great
great great great grandkids will be able
to see it his great great grandkids and
see his moments see his bus see his
jacket and say man
what's in him is in me and I can do
great things and that's what it's all
about it's about him inspiring them
don't be so caught up on the fight
between these reporters or writers that
you miss the fight for you hurry for
your generation for four generations to
come and your family and what I call
generational blessings tours or vans do
you think that's all it that it is it's
the reason why he's not here have you
spoken on III talk to him you know
before I went on and I haven't spoken to
him since before I went on the NFL
Network and I think he got upset better
I saw his I saw his tweet yeah I ended
that with cuz I ended it with I know T
oh you know he showed up when he didn't
get in with the go jacket that he had
paid for with all of his records on and
I and it does it baffles me how how do
you buy your jacket when you don't get
in but when you do get in you you the
real jacket you say yeah I don't want
that that's just hard and and we pray
for them and we love them and and we're
looking forward to them walking in that
room one day and experiencing all of it
before I let you go what's latest with
DES is best you can tell well thank you
I can tell you that I know people have
been reaching out to him in trying to
get him I've talked with a few teams
that have tried to reach out to him and
trying to get him to come in I've talked
with some some some GM's I've talked to
officer coordinators that that that's it
if we get him in Michael III get him
some give him some balls get him some
targets and everything but things just
haven't worked out and I'm gonna tell
you what worries me rich because I
understand his plan he says he wants to
try to lock on to a team and play for a
year and then maybe come back and get
him a bigger deal but each day goes by
that becomes
and less of a possibility because now
whenever you get to a team you got to
learn a whole new system and I'm gonna
tell you something that's wide reciever
the surest way to lose in this game is
when you're leaving a huddle trying to
figure out what route do I run on this
play instead of leaving that huddle
saying how do I win on this route and
there's right now we'll be leaving in a
huddle saying oh god what rap do I run
on this play so he's already at a
deficit yeah I just hope he gets with
somebody that's smart enough to say I'm
gonna give them a package and each week
I'm going to extend that package so we
can get the best day is that you're
playing football is that another way of
saying that wherever he winds up Irv you
won't line up in the same damn place 17
straight weeks same place for the first
few weeks because he's got to learn one
spot before he can learn another spot so
that that that's the situation he's
going to have to deal with it hopefully
he'll get a smart coordinate office
coordinator that knows how to integrate
him slowly love seeing you man and so we
by the way I do believe this because
I've seen it everybody come and go you
may have the most tailored gold jacket
out of everybody seriously it is
tailored right there yeah I didn't take
it off the first few nights I did I
really can say I slept in everything
it's just it just means that much to me
you know it means that much a lot of
guys you know array I watch it on our
network you watch when listen Baker
knocked on that door
oh yeah and random all just bust out
crime and I was like man I was almost
crying at home watch there's amazing
tonight the Jack Morrison on that on the
network time if he if he cried oh not
from David big wait did he watch out
that Jeff is one of my that's the whole
other thing that's one of my favorite
moments
let you go I'd take a break Troy
Vincent's gonna join that the year that
Shannon Sharpe made it and sterling
slipped the jacket on him yeah and they
both started crying and hugging in the
middle of they can't not ignore him
right it was really so moving it was
incredible and it was the front page
photograph of the Canton repository the
Canton newspaper here okay front page
fault before and it's just because it
means I get goosebumps remembering it
it's what's it about this is what you're
so passionate about it's that moment the
moment family Brotherhood figurative
Brotherhood literal brother literal
family hard work sweat tears sterling
not being able to have a career I
exactly would hotel lobby the next
morning and there was Deacon Jones
holding up
that front page in front of sterling and
Shannon barking at them for crying it
was incredible exactly
and I said that as I said I hate that
Till's out here so we can make him sit
there shut up just like Louis good
Taylor co-branded Brian don't they can't
say a word I gotta take it like I'm
mayor just sit here and wait and that me
that makes it fun love that we have so
much fun
earth love you will see I'll see you
this weekend poor oh yeah part of the
NFL Network covered yeah oh my god
that's Michael Irvin here Rich Eisen
show right here from Canton Ohio the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience